can we do okay Jenny J blog says can we
do an improv story like what we did
about the werecats and by the ways you
guys Rock oh we could do that yeah sure
we need an idea of like the basis of
where was it one word or one sentence in
one sentence we were telling the story a
little bit okay so we're like what's
going on in this what's happening yes
that's exactly what we're doing right
start to it
okay so we're off okay so it was crazy
like this crazy story like about three
years ago we're all in an abandoned
Victoria's Secret store and we were
hunting ghosts we heard they was
haunting everyone who had gone in this
mall was coming out like turn off the
music for this cuz it's gonna get spooky
yeah no no everyone can add musically so
anyway we're haunting these Victoria's
Secret model ghosts cuz we know that
they hang out at stores there's no
Molly's normal this was the one store
that they all went to and they all went
to this one store in the middle of
Kansas Missouri Missouri we went over to
Kansas Missouri Kansas City and then
what was your so we approached the
[Laughter]
should probably equip ourselves before
we went into the haunted Victorian we
went in naked completely naked don't do
that either because there's some sharp
objects in a poke yeah
[Laughter]
entering the store we see all of the
ghost hunting equipment on the right and
the regular hunting on the left and of
course Wade goes over to the regular
hunting because he doesn't understand
that we're after the super model ghosts
like we have no idea what we're doing
we're just a bunch of idiots that
wandered to Kansas Missouri no reason
except hunt super model ghosts so we
grabbed the hunting rifles and we make
our way confidently and naked Lee over
to the Victoria see we're naked
completely naked with our hunting rifles
no bullets by the way into the store cuz
we didn't want to hurt anybody
yeah we're like looking through and all
of a sudden we turned into the lingerie
department which is the whole store we
see the pretty long video he was working
on he needed some super awesome what
better way to get to my secret so we got
together and found a couple dogs and
Freddie Wong and Mark shared morning
Tyler night
Tyler please all right so we're looking
in our double thongs staring up at this
horror flying thing and we see that it's
obviously the goats um you okay you want
to take over no it's a ghost so Freddie
Wong leans over to us and goes we gotta
get this ghost did you bring your girls
hunting equipment and then Tyler goes he
says sure and he pulls out of his song
the ultimate ghost rate is shooted the
honky
[Laughter]
you wanted to shoot some ectoplasm
and then we've got nothing work ghosts
at all of sexual supermodels look like
pretty ridiculous
because it turns out we were
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
turtles dildo shopping whoo giant
attacking dildos no dildos attacked it
was a normal night we were over at
Wade's we were debating whether we're
gonna go to Chuck E Cheese or not like
cuz it was his birthday he was just
turning 12 it was amazing then all of a
sudden wow the sky
dildos rained like rain raining dildos
were eggs exactly old ladies were
getting pummeled by dildos my brain
fried so old ladies were getting
pummeled by dildos and all said they
were eggs so and they turn it yes
hatched from the dildos and weight does
not a damn thing to say about it now I
get okay so the old lady's getting hit
by the hatching means and all of the
grandpas city holy grandma they came out
with their umbrellas trying to shield
the lace from the booms just to find out
[Music]
yes they look we were just watching
waiting for the and then the point is we
were waiting out the storm and then
blamo we just said happened and it all
went to hell because we decided we were
going to hide and wait sex dungeon
basement that was filled with other
dildos all right yes we were waiting in
the sex dungeon filled with Dylan is the
only way to fight dildos so you went
from the basement we could hear the dill
made oh of the dill hurricane falling
with it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
and we
[Laughter]
glad you didn't cuz the dildo trees are
good enough for me or no they're not you
know what I mean
with a dildo bill Deitz lights that's
why we celebrate build Annika the end
that one builder lasted for 14 days
[Laughter]